foreign
[Music]
hello everyone thank you for joining and
thanks to the organizers for inviting me
to speak today I'm really glad to be
participating in this year's genetics
virtual week my name is Tracy Bedrosian
and I'm based at The Institute for
genomic medicine at Nationwide
Children's Hospital where one of the
things that we're very interested in is
how thematic mutations in our patients
with epilepsy contribute to brain
development and disease
we've recently been using a variety of
genomic approaches including long-leaf
sequencing to characterize thematic
mosaicism observed in surgically
resected patient brain samples
today I'm going to tell you about a
patient with a very unique brain
mosaicism to show how we applied
long-read sequencing among other
techniques to better understand the
contribution of somatic mutations to his
disease
so I'm going to start with an overview
of somatic mosaicism and then talk a
little bit about the consequences of
pathogenic somatic mutations in brain
development especially as related to
brain malformations and epileptic
disorders
after that I'll talk a little bit about
our translational research study that we
have here at Nationwide Children's to
identify brain somatic mosaicism in
patients with seizure disorders
I'll present one specific case in depth
as an example of how we're applying
genomics to better understand mosaicism
in our patients
and because this talk is part of the
long read sequencing track of genetics
virtual week I'll just highlight that
we're going to talk about two ways that
we've used long-range sequencing to
learn about brain mosaicism
one is to phase thematic variance and
the other is to genotype cells in single
cell rna-seq datasets but more on that
later
first let's Dive Right In with a little
background on genetic mosaicism
so at the most simple level of genetics
we think about how you inherit your DNA
from your parents and that genetic code
is present in every cell of your body
but as cells divide during development
there's also the potential for errors in
DNA replication and repair to occur
during each cell division
these genetic changes that are acquired
rather than inherited are known as
somatic mutations
when a somatic variant arises it'll be
passed on to daughter cells of that
lineage depending on how often mutations
are acquired and precisely when they're
required a person can end up with
varying levels of mosaicism throughout
the body where some cells have
numbers
the distribution of this mosaicism can
look very different depending on when
and where the mutation occurred any
given somatic mutation could affect
cells throughout the whole body a
particular germ layer or a single organ
so we happen to be most interested in
brain restricted somatic mosaicism for a
couple of reasons for one neurons are
among the longest lived cells in the
body so somatic mutations in the brain
have a unique potential to influence
brain function throughout the entire
lifetime of an individual
in addition there are some
well-characterized instances of somatic
mutations causing neurological disease
which I'll talk more about in a moment
but first let me talk for a moment about
how brain specific mosaicism is
generated
so during the first and second
trimesters of gestation this is a really
prolific time in terms of cell division
giving rise to the cells that will make
up the mature brain and because of all
the cell division taking place this is
also a time of susceptibility to
acquiring somatic mutations
if a somatic mutation occurs for example
in a neural progenitor cell
all of the daughter cells will then have
that same mutation leading to a unique
genotype that's not found elsewhere in
the body outside of the brain and also
not found in other brain cells that
originated from separate lineages
whether a somatic variant manifests in
terms of some kind of appreciable
phenotype really depends on a number of
factors including the nature of the
specific variant itself
the genetic background of the individual
its developmental timing the affected
cell lineages and the number of cells
affected
and just to give a couple of examples we
know that the same variant can have very
different effects depending on whether
it's restricted to say excitatory
neurons versus glia versus brain
vasculature
likewise the same variant could have
different overall effects on the brain
depending on whether it's restricted to
a small number of cells in one anatomic
region or if it's widely expressed in an
entire hemisphere
and finally the genetic background of
the individual can be an important
determinant as well as some phenotypes
can be caused by so-called second hit
somatic mutations in a gene that's
already affected by germline variation
so you can see how brain somatic
mosaicism can be a rather complex player
in brain phenotypes
now it's also worth mentioning briefly
that many types of somatic mutations
contribute to the overall genetic
diversity of the brain these can be
small changes like single nucleotide
variants and small indels larger
structural variants copy number variants
inversions translocations even whole
chromosomal gains or losses as well as
things like mobile element insertions
as I mentioned somatic mutations are a
recognized contributor to
neurodevelopmental disease one of the
most well-studied clinical
manifestations of brain mosaicism is
malformations of cortical development
these are a major cause of drum
resistant epilepsy in children who
typically require surgical resection of
the abnormal brain tissue in order to
treat the seizures
until relatively recently the etiology
of these malformations was unknown
although it's now becoming clear that
brain specific somatic mutations are a
cause for many of these cases
there are a variety of different
cortical malformations caused by somatic
mutations but I'll just highlight two
that will come up in this talk
so one is focal cortical dysplasia which
is a focal malformation classified based
on the cellular pathology observed type
1 FCD is characterized by abnormal
cortical lamination and up to a third of
these cases have a somatic mutation in
the slc35a2 gene
type 2 FCD is characterized by
dysmorphic neurons and about half of
these cases have a mosaic mutation in an
mtor pathway gene on the order of one to
ten percent of cells affected
hemimegalencephaly which is a
malformation characterized by overgrowth
of an entire brain hemisphere is also
associated with mtor pathway mutations
but at a higher rate of 10 to 60 percent
of cells affected
so now that you have a little bit of
context I'd like to tell you briefly
about the work we're doing at Nationwide
Children's Hospital to better understand
and treat children with epilepsy and
cortical malformations originating from
brain somatic mutations
and I should say this is a huge
collaborative effort among both research
and clinical teams
so uh we have an IRB approved research
study to consent patients undergoing
surgical resection of brain tissue at
Nationwide Children's for treating
intractable epilepsy
we have enrolled close to 50 patients to
date representing a variety of different
developmental malformations
patients typically undergo EEG studies
prior to their surgical research
in order to pinpoint the anatomic origin
of their seizures
the resected tissue is then sent for
pathology as usual and then leftover
further material is provided to us for
genomic analysis as part of our research
study
we perform exome and RNA sequencing on
paired blood and brain samples
and we'll call somatic variants in each
of data and evaluate those based on a
set of criteria where we're looking for
variants that are rare in population
databases supported by a minimal number
of reads an absent from the blood
comparator
we've also curated a database of
epilepsy-associated genes which we'll
use to help us hone in on interesting
candidates
after filtering through all of our
criteria will typically be left with a
relatively small list of less than 10
somatic variants as candidates for the
patient's phenotype
we'll also check whether those variants
are expressed in RNA and take a look at
the overall picture of gene expression
we'll report any candidate variants back
to the clinical team for follow-up if
it's appropriate and from there we let
the findings from our patients guide
functional studies in the lab so that we
can gain a deeper understanding of how
these genes and variants contribute to
brain development
so recently a one-year-old male
undergoing hemispherectomy for
left-sided hemegal encephaly and
intractable epilepsy was consented to
our research protocol
as you can see his MRI showed overgrowth
of the entire left cerebral and
cerebellar hemispheres
now this patient had a fairly unusual
malformation in that there was an
anterior to posterior gradient of
severity which you can really appreciate
from the bottom image here
the anterior cerebrum was enlarged with
abnormalities in the cortical
architecture but the posterior cerebrum
was much more severely affected with a
flat simplified cortical surface and
severely enlarged neurons as you can see
by this neuronal staining
at three months old he experienced his
first hemutonic colonic seizure and then
worsened over time with medically
refractory epilepsy at 14 months old he
underwent the hemispherectomy and 15
different brain specimens were collected
for our genomic sequencing protocol
to search for brain somatic mutations we
began by performing exome sequencing of
resected brain tissue from section K
which was within one of the more severe
regions of pathology
there were only two somatic mutations
that passed all of our filtering
criteria and amazingly both were in the
same gene P10
the first mutation was a complex indole
at the beginning of Exon 5
and the second mutation was a two base
duplication in Exon 9.
both of these variants were frame shifts
and expected to have an effect at the
protein level
by examining the translated protein
sequence for each variant we predicted
that the Exon 5 variant should introduce
an early stop codon therefore truncating
the protein
the Exon 9 variant was predicted to
result in a late stop codon thus
altering the protein structure
now we know that mutations that disrupt
P10 can lead to Downstream activation of
mtor which is a known mechanism of
hemimetalencephaly
mtor signaling promotes growth and
activating mutations along this pathway
are associated with various overgrowth
syndromes
brain somatic variance in genes all
along this pathway really have been
associated with both hemimegalencephaly
as well as focalcortical dysplasia
and furthermore germline mutations in
P10 are known to cause a P10 hematoma
tumor syndrome
um
which is or can be associated with brain
overgrowth as well
we also know that somatic mutations that
activate this mtor pathway can manifest
differently depending on the proportion
of cells affected which is related to
how early in development the mutation
arose therefore we were very interested
in both of these P10 variants as
potential contributors to the patient's
unique malformation where one segment
was more severely affected than the
other
foreign
characterizing these variants was to
determine their distribution across the
entire hemisphere
we investigated the variant
distributions across anatomic regions by
performing targeted sequencing of P10 at
approximately 2000 x average read depth
across all of the available brain
specimens and blood
the Exon 5 indel which is shown here in
blue was detected in all of the
different brain sites throughout the
whole Hemisphere and was detected in
blood at 2.95 frequency showing this
variant is also Mosaic outside of the
brain
the Exon 9 duplication was detected only
in the posterior cerebrum which
correlated with the presence of the more
severe neuropathology findings
next We performed bulk tissue RNA
sequencing on all 15 sections and
calculated the expressed variant allele
fractions
again we observed the Exon 5 variant
present throughout the entire hemisphere
that the Exon 9 variant being expressed
only in posterior regions of the brain
asked whether the two P10 variants were
present on the same allele or up the
alleles because this could have
functional implications
the presence of two disrupted P10
alleles could potentially lead to a more
severe effect than having one disrupted
allele and one normal allele
and this is the first instance I'll tell
you about where long read sequencing
enabled us to answer our question
so using traditional short read
technology we could not obtain reads
containing variants because they were
too far apart in the gene
we had a number of reads but no
practical way to tell if they were
coming from the same allele or not with
long read sequencing we knew that we
could obtain reads of many kilobases
long that would span both variant
positions allowing us to accurately
phase these two somatic variants
so we used the PAC bio platform to
perform ISO seek long-read sequencing of
RNA from the patient's posterior
cerebrum and we obtained 21 full-length
reads spanning both variant positions
and this is a split screen view from igb
that shows the same reads of positions
over Exon 5 and Exon 9. Within These
views you can see reads that contain the
deletion at the beginning of Exon 5 and
one read that contains the two base pair
insertion in Exon 9 but you see none of
the reads contain both variants together
and out of the total 21 reads that we
obtained 14 expressed the Exon 5 variant
33 expressed the Exon 9 variant and none
expressed both variance suggesting the
two are on opposite alleles meaning that
when present together in the same cell
they could cause a complete biolic
disruption of the gene which would
potentially be more severe than having a
single affected allele coming back to
this um this observation of a spectrum
of severity of the patient's
malformation
our next step in characterizing this
mosaicism was to ask how the presence of
one or both somatic P10 variants might
affect the brain transcriptome using our
rna-seq data
sections harboring the Exon 5 variant
alone clearly clustered separately from
sections containing both variants in a
principal component analysis
those sections also had a strong
upregulation of genes involved in
puppies such as inflammation and amateur
signaling suggesting a more severe loss
of P10 does Drive hyperactivity of the
mtor pathway in the patient's posterior
brain
to confirm activation of mtor signaling
We performed immunohistochemistry for
phospho S6 ribosomal protein which is
upregulated by mtor
section c from the posterior cerebrum
showed high levels of phospho S6
staining compared to section A from the
anterior part of the brain
and the intense staining corresponded to
the enlarged and dysmorphic neurons that
were observed in the neuropathology
these results suggest that there is
variation in the extent of mtor
activation due to the presence of one or
both somatic mutations which may lead to
the variable degree of cortical
malformation that was seen in this
patient
but this led to a question in our minds
which was how the variants are
represented within certain cell types
which might further inform us on how
these variants contributed to the
patient's disease
so to better understand the contribution
of these thematic Mosaic variants to
particular cell types we turn to high
throughput single cell 3 Prime RNA
sequencing using the 10x genomics
platform in order to identify and
characterize an unbiased sampling of all
of the cells present in the tissue
in this system we're able to isolate
nuclei from Frozen patient brain tissue
and then capture those nuclei such that
we add cell specific barcodes to every
RNA molecule
those barcoded rnas are reverse
transcribed and Amplified
fragmented and then the three prime
tails are sequenced using Illumina
technology
the advantage of this three prime
approach is that you can generate gene
expression data from many many cells and
molecules at much higher throughput and
lower cost than would be possible if the
entire transcripts were sequenced
we cannot assign genotyped individual
cells if the variant positions are not
located at the very end of the Gene and
that's really what we wanted to do here
so this is
where we turn to Long read sequencing to
help answer our question
we adapted the 10x genomics protocol to
incorporate pack bio isoc long-rate
sequencing of the full length barcoded
transcripts
this allowed us to sequence all the way
from the cell barcode as the three prime
end of the gene through both P10 variant
positions in one single read
briefly prior to fragmentation a portion
of the full-length barcoded cdna was set
aside and further Amplified
we used a panel of capture probes to
enrich P10 transcripts and then
generated libraries for isoseq and we
sequence them on the SQL 2 platform
we analyzed our gene expression data in
R using the syrup package and we
overlaid the genotype information from
the targeted long-read data set by
extracting the mutation status from each
long read at each variant position and
then matching the cell barcodes to those
in the gene expression data set
so to show you what that looks like in
the Illumina data set the nuclei
clustered into nine major groups that we
identified based on marker gene
expression to represent various cell
types for example neurons astrocytes as
well as some immune cells derived from
the periphery such as T cells
we obtained pack bio coverage for a
subset of those cells shown on the right
where dark gray represents cells that
Express the reference sequence and blue
and orange represent cells expressing
our variance
this overlay revealed that each variant
was expressed by about 12 percent of
cells in total from this piece of tissue
which is close to the variant allele
fractions derived from bulk RNA
sequencing
no longer you've expressed both variants
in the same read although one cell an
oligodendrocyte expressed both variants
on separate reads confirming the two are
on opposite alleles
the proportion of mutant cells within
each cell type however was different for
each variant the Exon 5 variant was
observed in multiple cell types
including microglia and perivascular
cells both of which originate from the
mesoderm during development in contrast
to other CNS cell types which are
ectodermal
this agrees with our finding that the
Exon 5 variant was indeed present in the
patient's blood at low frequency
suggesting he is Mosaic for this variant
in multiple tissues and germ layers
it also suggests this Exon 5 variant
arose at a very early stage of
development before germ layer
specification
the Exon 9 variant which was not
detected in led by Deep sequencing was
mostly restricted to ectodermal CNS cell
types
surprisingly one cell containing the
Exon 9 variant was observed in a
mesodermal cell type which was a
macrophage raising the possibilities of
this variant is also Mosaic outside the
brain at a very low level but we would
have to do additional studies to confirm
that
interestingly there was one cell
population that was not readily
identified
it expressed some neuronal markers but
also strong signatures of signal
transduction and even mtor signaling we
reason that these cells may represent
disease-involved neurons and in support
of that this population showed the
highest proportion of variant cells with
almost 50 percent of genotype cells
expressing one of the P10 variants
overall this analysis suggests a
developmental history for the patient's
somatic mutations where they arose
sequentially on opposite alleles
probably with the Exon 5 variant
occurring earlier in development and
then contributed to different
proportions of cell types in the
maturing brain
lastly it's worth noting that sequencing
analyzes could have unanticipated
clinical implications for patients
so germline variance in P10 have been
associated with tumor predisposition
syndromes in this case our deep
sequencing and single cell sequencing
demonstrated that the patient's somatic
variants at least the Exon 9 variant
were present not just in neurons but in
cells from multiple germ layers raising
the possibility of increased risk of
certain Cancers and other tissues
throughout the body
because of those results we took the
findings back to the provider who
ordered clinical confirmation
samples submitted for clinical Stinger
sequencing validation confirmed the Exon
5 variant in a buccal swab sample in
addition to brain tissue and now this
finding of somatic mosaicism will be
entered into the patient's medical
record and the patient will now have the
opportunity for increased clinical
surveillance throughout his lifetime
and that might not have been detected in
the clinical context had we not studied
the affected tissue of origin or
performed these kinds of analyzes
in summary instances of mosaicism like
this one provide a unique opportunity to
study the developmental implications of
different Gene disruptions and in this
context we were able to identify brain
somatic mutations of P10 as a disease
mechanism of hemimetalencephaly
we also observed that a more severe
clinical phenotype is associated with
anatomical regions of double mosaicism
although we took advantage of a number
of genomic techniques to learn about the
mosaicism observed in this particular
patient long read sequencing really
enabled us to go one step further and
answer questions that otherwise would
have been very difficult to answer
so with that I'd like to take a moment
to acknowledge everyone who contributed
to this work the studies that I have
talked about here represent a huge
collaborative effort by these folks and
others so many thanks to them and thank
you for listening